what about our science graduates so
do you think they have some good
opportunities in uh hardcore
injuring firms
oh yes absolutely
so this was actually
posted by one of our community members
so
oh yes absolutely i mean if you talk
about just you know hardcore engineering
form that i'm talking about
if you talk about pharmaceutical
industries dr reddy's lab for example in
india talking about the indian context
or mnc in india right
they have a huge demand for chemists
right biochemists
what about physicists
yeah okay we're coming to that now
uh even physicists given you know we
work on fluid mechanics heat transfer
beyond the point what are in research is
physics right yes and even when our
collaborators
a lot of our collaborators in foreign
universities are part of applied physics
or theoretical physics or you may
sometimes apply maths
yeah that's i'm even keeping
publications etc aside now yeah
okay now uh
i'll tell you my
when i went to colorado the department
chair was actually an indian bengali
chair of mechanical engineering you know
what was his background applied
mathematics
he's a math graduate then he started
working on applied problems then he
figured out most of the problems that
he's solving is in the realm of solid
mechanics
and that's how
he got into mechanical engineering okay
similarly the person i learned numeric
analysis from
he was working on hardcore fluid
dynamics computational fluid dynamics as
part of applied maths department
so this is academia but again let's come
to industry now
again if you talk about ge
material scientists
thermal
aviation industry thermal barrier
coatings
okay or development of new materials for
different products
okay there's a huge demand of material
scientists
absolutely
okay even today also some of the things
that you work on or
some of us work on on microfluidics it's
about changing the surface uh surface
wettability
right it's a materials thing fine
eventually okay
it's you know the batteries
uh has
an absolute right an urgent need for
chemists and coming back here i was
coming next to that electric mobility
lithium-ion batteries sodium and
batteries yes okay
even you know at intel i i was working
on electronics packaging
first of all
microprocessors came from semiconductor
physics
right keep that in mind many of the
old-time electronic semiconductor
experts and electronics engineers
are from physics background including
the people founded probably they didn't
have electronics departments back then
correct so electronics department was
actually
goes back and forth
yes finds his foundations in physics
okay
and if you today also if you go to
electronics industry there are lots of
physicists who are working there
okay
material scientists
even in packaging types of
soldered materials for example you know
i'll take you just
just the basic one one example which is
which has led to a change worldwide
and that is about uh lead free solder if
you look at electronics products
the lead tin solder was traditionally
used
but then under rohs which is reduction
of hazardous substances from 2006
onwards
the lead containing solder is banned
so now people are working on what is
called the sac which is tin silver and
copper base cell based solder materials
so entire shift in the industry
they're still trying to find out what is
optimal composition and what are the
proper desirable properties what is the
composition that will take us to the
most desirable properties whether it's
electrical whether it's thermal whether
it's structural etcetera
so that's the materials problem so and
so examples abound everywhere
um all right so i definitely see that
science graduates have a lot of
a lot of scope you just have to work on
the right problems
and
and they can keep your eyes and ears
open
i'll write
since maybe i'll just add one more point
please
this is
another you know something that our phd
students have to come out
is that you should be ready you have
worked on some domain or some realm in
your phd fine absolutely fine
but as i was telling that phd is not
about solving a specific problem it's
about gaining the acquiring the skills
to work on problems the solutions to
which is unknown
or solutions to which are unknown
and it's this
the skill set that you have developed
which should give you the confidence
that i should be able to solve any other
problem
so this is another thing again taking a
cue of your last question as well that
what should be what should the students
do
i see many people
okay what have you worked on this what
would you like to work on yeah i would
like to work on a further extension of
this etcetera etcetera
i've seen people in in job interviews
phd students when they ask okay what do
you want to if you do you have any
questions from us they say
yeah i wanted to ask what is the scope
of publishing papers while working in
this come on publishing papers is not
the priority of an industry that cannot
be your top question in an indus in an
interview that may be your personal
aspiration
but your industry is not going to employ
you to publish papers let me tell you
that